[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
mitri sirin guten abend der krieg in der
ukraine wieder ein schwerpunkt bei uns
und katja die sportliche situation von
russland schreitet weiter voran ja immer
mehr verwendet sie nach schönen guten
abend auch heute beleuchten wir die
dramatische und verzweifelte situation
der menschen in diesem krieg aus
verschiedenen perspektiven
luftbilder zeigen eine rund 64 kilometer
lange kolonne panzer lkw schweres gerät
putins feldzug im visier die hauptstadt
kiew
im nordosten im zentrum der zweitgrößten
stadt kharkiv schlagen raketen ein
moskau beteuert aber weiter keine
zivilen ziele zu bombardieren
mehr als 600.000 menschen sind
inzwischen nach un-angaben vor der
gewalt ins ausland geflohen und der
ukrainische präsident seelen ski wendet
sich per videoschalte an die eu
parlamentarier in brüssel ein
dramatischer hilferuf richtung europa
das alles haben wir für sie im blick
nato militär experten sagen dass
russland innerhalb der nächsten 48 bis
72 stunden mit geballtem
militärpotenzial versuchen wird die
großen städte einzunehmen schlimmste es
steht zu befürchten
im krieg bleibt die wahrheit schnell auf
der strecke was beide seiten behaupten
lässt sich oft nicht unabhängig
überprüfen thomas garcia und christoph
distel über die aktuelle situation
heute mitten in rackith einen
bombeneinschlag gefilmt von einer
überwachungskamera ein angriff aufs
regionalparlament im gebäude tragen sie
verletzte heraus versuchen sich in
sicherheit zu bringen draußen auf dem
friedensplatz bleiben nur trümmer
verwüstung tote wie viele unklar
auch diese bilder kommen aus kharkiv
eine granate in einer küche das geschoss
soll eine frau getötet haben das ebenso
wie das video nicht vollständig
verifizierbar klar nur die stadtbewohner
haben angst der 32 jährige alexej lebt
mit seiner frau und der acht monate
alten tochter im keller eines hochhauses
wir sahen viele autos die von bomben
getroffen wurden manche menschen
verbrannten darin
meine frau hat jeden tag mehr angst von
kriegsverbrechen spricht der präsident
es gab dort in rackith kein
militärisches ziel ebenso wenig wie in
den wohngegenden der stadt die von
artillerie getroffen wurden es ist
offener unverhüllt terror
russland widerspricht man habe nur
militärische ziele angegriffen mit
präzisionswaffen und
die ukraine zögert nicht zivilisten als
menschliche schutzschilde zu
missbrauchen
raketenabschuss systeme waffen
granatwerfer der verteidigungsminister
sein in zivilen gebäuden untergebracht
russisches militär rückt unterdessen vor
neben kharkiv gerät auch die hauptstadt
immer stärker unter druck ein
militärkonvoi 60 kilometer lang nähert
sich kiew letzte position gut 20
kilometer vom stadtkern diese us
satelliten bilder sollen den
fahrzeugtross zeigen und diese videos
einwohner der metropole die fliehen
bereits getroffen der fernsehturm mehr
militär mehr angriffe zeichen einer
veränderung also nachdem es in den
ersten kriegstagen für die russen
unerwartet langsam voran gegangen ist
müssen die russen jetzt versuchen neue
kräfte einzuführen die praktisch über
die alten die bisher da sind in vor
allen dingen im norden von kiew hinweg
angreifen und auf diese art und weise
dem angriff wieder schwung zu geben
das ist ein moment um im gefecht welches
die russen aus ihrer sicht erhalten
müssen und wo ich der auffassung bin
dass wenn die ukrainische streitkräfte
in der form weiter kämpfen bisher getan
haben die russen auch damit
schwierigkeiten bekommen werden etwas
davon zeigt der blick auf den süden zwar
gibt es dort große geländegewinne an der
küste mario pohl ist ohne strom aber
auch gegenwehr gibt es milito pohl
unbewaffnet gegen putins truppen
harmonie geht nach hause rufen die
ukraine friedlicher widerstand im
kriegsgebiet am sechsten tag des
russischen einmarsches
[Musik]
westlich von kiew es für uns katrin
eigendorf kathrin es deutet einiges auf
eine russische großoffensive auf kiew in
was können wir uns über die aktuellen
geschehnisse berichten
ja alles deutet darauf hin dass putin in
den nächsten stunden die hauptstadt kiew
massiv angreifen will es gerade dabei
und das hören wir aus verschiedenen
kreisen
kommunikationsanlagen
infrastrukturanlagen lahmzulegen
so kann man auch die bombardierung des
fernsehturms erklären und im prinzip
muss man sagen an diesem sechsten tag
des krieges zeichnet sich ab dass putin
immer härter auch gegen zivilisten
vorgehen wird es handelt sich hier
wirklich um eine systematische
bombardierung und angriffe auf
zivilisten das haben wir in kharkiv
erlebt das werden wir so prognostizieren
ist im prinzip alle experten auch in
kiew erleben das ist das was putin im
moment als strategie verfolgt es ist
überhaupt gar keine
verhandlungsbereitschaft im moment bei
russischer seite zu erkennen sondern die
bevölkerung soll hier im prinzip in
angst und schrecken versetzt werden und
man merkt auch dass die stimmung jetzt
so langsam kippt und die leute wirklich
auch mit großer sorge die dieses kriegs
geschehen verfolgen dass es auch immer
eben mehr opfer gibt und viele leute
erleben wir einfach auch die jetzt in
tränen aufgelöst sind und weinen und
sagen ja wir werden widerstand leisten
aber wir müssen uns hier wirklich darauf
einrichten dass
dieser krieg passive opfer der
zivilbevölkerung fordern wird ukraine
kiew steht möglicherweise die schlimmste
nacht bevor bislang dankeschön für die
schilderung katrin eigendorf
ja die russische führung zeigt sich
weiter entschlossen
verteidigungsminister schoigu sagt man
werde die angriffe so lange fortsetzen
bis alle ziele erreicht seien russlands
außenminister lawrow verteidigte das
vorgehen und bezeichnete die westlichen
sanktionen als illegal er war per video
zum un menschenrechtsrat zugeschaltet
aus protest verließen dutzende
delegierte die sitzung zur begründung
sagten sie der menschenrechtsrat dürfe
nicht als plattform für desinformation
missbraucht werden und wir jetzt
christiansen in moskau dazu christian
wie sind die politischen äußerungen der
russischen regierungsvertreter jetzt
einzuschätzen
ja man sieht hier ganz klar dass eine
kompromissbereitschaft überhaupt nicht
zu erkennen ist am kreml sprecher paskov
hat sich heute auch noch mal geäußert
und gesagt sie versuchen uns mit den
sanktionen dazu zu zwingen unsere
position zu ändern aber wir werden
unsere position nicht ändern und jetzt
eben kurz vor der sendung kam noch eine
andere meldung dass die führung hier
noch mal massiv gegen die wenigen
verbliebenen freien medien vorgeht und
zwar gegen den radiosender echo aus
moskau
und gegen den fernsehsender tvs dass den
sendern wird vorgeworfen inhalte
verbreitet zu haben mit denen die
führung hin nicht einverstanden ist ich
kenne die internetseiten dort war
relativ ausführlich über den konflikt
jetzt berichtet worden und ihm wurde
gedroht dass der zugang jetzt erschwert
wird und jetzt wenige sekunden vor
unserem gespräch warum diese seiten in
russland auch nicht mehr erreichbar
immer stärker wird russland ja vom
westen isoliert wir nehmen sie das wahr
christian
es wird immer klarer wie diese
sanktionen hier wirken die menschen
merken dass auf der straße an den
geldautomaten und es zieht ja wirklich
große kreise wenn wir sehen es läuft auf
der diplomatischen ebene in der politik
in der wirtschaft im sport große firmen
ziehen ihr kapital aus dem land und das
kommt in der wirtschaft so langsam an
und auch bei den menschen und viele
können sich noch überhaupt nicht
vorstellen welchen einfluss das hat
langfristig auf das land haben wird aber
ich habe das gefühl dass die sorge bei
vielen menschen immer größer wird danke
nach moskau christiansen
jetzt ins herz der europäischen politik
nach brüssel dort kam das
europaparlament zusammen um weiter über
die aktuelle situation zu beraten die
farben blau gelb überall präsent wieder
wurde ukraine präsident live dazu
geschaltet er warb eindringlich für die
aufnahme seines landes in die eu ina
baltes über die sehr emotionale sitzung
und die großen solidaritätsbekundungen
der parlamentarier
ein ewiger applaus symbol der
hochachtung vor wolodimir selensky der
heute zugeschaltet ist direkt aus kiew
ins eu parlament
wir kämpfen auch dafür dass wir
gleichberechtigte mitglieder europas
werden und ich hoffe dass wir am
heutigen tag jetzt allen zeigen können
dass wir europäer sind wir sind die
europäische union
brüssel ist formell und so hat sie
lenski gestern in diesem brief die eu
mitgliedschaft beantragt doch bei allem
blau-gelb heute zügig kann das nicht
gehen alle 27 mitgliedsstaaten müssen
zustimmen damit aufnahmegespräche
beginnen könnten für european junior
heute sind sich die eu und die ukraine
näher als je zuvor aber es ist auch noch
ein weiter weg vor uns das parlament hat
eine resolution verabschiedet man werde
auf eine aufnahme hinarbeiten heißt es
darin wir können nicht einfach von heute
auf morgen einen staat aufnehmen auch
wenn wir mit diesem start absolut
solidarisch sind und alles tun um diesen
staat in seiner selbstverteidigung zu
hell immerhin der beitritt der ukraine
ist jetzt gesprächsthema in der eu und
so ende dieser tag der solidarität und
symbolik mit der hymne der ukraine
mitten in brüssel
[Musik]
solidarität für die ukraine sanktionen
gegen russland und bundeskanzler scholz
hat heute weitere angekündigt er traf
sich mit luxemburgs regierungschef
battle nur eines von vielen
krisentreffen der westlichen verbündeten
battle rief deutschland und frankreich
auf diplomatische kanäle offen zu halten
um vielleicht doch noch zu einer
waffenruhe zu kommen last bohnsack über
diplomatie im angesicht des krieges es
sind nicht viele die heute gegen den
russischen angriffskrieg vom kanzleramt
demonstrieren aber auch sie wollen ein
zeichen setzen ähnlich wie der
vizekanzler in washington der die
schlagkraft der sanktionen gegen
russland unterstreicht wir haben gesehen
dass die maßnahmen die ergriffen worden
die sanktionen die wirtschaftssanktionen
die sanktion gegen den finanzmarkt eine
starke wirkung erzielt haben eine so
starke wirkung dass sie auch sicherlich
schon mittelfristig die russische
wirtschaft hart treffen werden
krisendiplomatie auch im polnischen lodz
aussenministerin berbalk macht gemeinsam
mit ihrem polnischen und französischen
amtskollegen klar wie wichtig es sei
dass europa zusammen steht glaubt hat
dass wir europäer in schockstarre
verharren der hat sich deutlich
getäuscht und vor allen dingen hat sich
der russische präsident getäuscht er hat
darauf spekuliert dass wir uns
auseinander treiben lassen aber das
gegenteil ist der fall und in berlin
trifft der bundeskanzler auf den
luxemburgischen ministerpräsidenten
beide glauben dass die situation noch
weiter eskalieren kann es wird jetzt
noch
eine ganz ganz dramatische zeit werden
und die bilder die wir bisher beklagen
mussten und über die wir bedrückt sind
mit den vielen toten und verletzten mit
den zerstörten gebäuden den zerstörten
infrastrukturen die werden nur ein
anfang sein von dem was wahrscheinlich
noch kommt wir sind jetzt in einer
situation wo wir aufpassen müssen es war
auch die erste frage ihrer kollegen dass
wir nicht in einen weltkrieg com
düstere warnungen grund genug für die
demonstranten draußen weiter zu
protestieren
[Musik]
es sind dunkle stunden die vereinten
nationen befürchten die größte
flüchtlingskrise in europa in diesem
jahrhundert denn seit beginn der
russischen invasion fliehen immer mehr
ukraine ins ausland nach un-angaben
haben mehr als
660.000 menschen die ukraine verlassen
die meisten hilfesuchenden flüchten ins
nachbarland polen laut dem polnischen
außenminister sind es rund 400.000
menschen mindestens 3000
kriegsflüchtlinge sind inzwischen in
deutschland angekommen roman leskovar
berichtet aus berlin nach einer langen
reise endlich angekommen drei
generationen von kindern bis großeltern
alle aus der ukraine julia hofer hat wie
so viele ukraine stämmige ihrer
verwandten bei sich aufgenommen die
anfahrt aus lemberg war extrem belastend
wir haben allein zwei nächte gebrauch
zur grenze dort mussten wir zwei weitere
nächte warten wir waren alle in einem
auto wir hatten panik angst wer die
möglichkeit hat versucht irgendwie raus
zu kommen
längst sind es nicht mehr nur ukraine
hierzulande die helfen auf telegramm
werden mittlerweile transfers aus polen
angeboten private unterkünfte vermittelt
auch auf dieser seite kann man eine
übernachtungsmöglichkeit anbieten viele
haben das bereits getan
julia hofer glaubt die meisten
geflohenen hoffen auf einen kurzen
aufenthalt in deutschland
eine zeitlang in der it-sicherheit zu
bleiben davor dass dieser krieg vorbei
ist auch am berliner hauptbahnhof wird
neuankömmlingen mittlerweile geholfen
von freiwilligen es gibt eine erste
verpflegung infos zum übernachten aber
auch kleinigkeiten wie lademöglichkeiten
fürs handy viele haben tatsächlich
verwandte sie haben ein ziel sie wollen
weiter
manche suchen aber auch eine unterkunft
weil sie erst mal nicht direkt wissen wo
sie hin können also sehr sehr
unterschiedlich aber alle sind sehr
erschöpft und sehr berlins erste
offizielle anlaufadresse bleibt das
ankunfts zentrum hier registrierte man
gestern 350 ukrainerinnen und ukrainer
deutlich mehr als an den vortagen
zweifellos viele menschen in der ukraine
brauchen jetzt dringend hilfe und sie
können spenden über das aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe
es unterstützt zb mit notunterkünften
bietet lebensmittel für
binnenflüchtlinge und leistet humanitäre
hilfe das stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine
bahn.de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100
weitere infos spenden zdf.de oder auf
der zdf textseite
der überfall russlands auf die ukraine
hat die deutsche sicherheitspolitik ja
völlig auf den kopf gestellt sie haben
die rede des kanzlers sicher noch im ohr
100 milliarden euro sollen schnell in
die verteidigung gesteckt werden ab
sofort und in den nächsten jahren soll
das budget massiv aufgestockt werden
aber was heißt das konkret und ab wann
wäre die bundeswehr in einem besseren
zustand als jetzt dazu ines trams
hier im ministerium sitzen sie derzeit
zusammen verteidigungsministerin
generalinspekteur die chefs der
teilstreitkräfte um zu überlegen wohin
mit den 100 milliarden euro es fehlt im
großen wie im kleinen
was sich des berufsverbandes braucht ein
sofortprogramm und das betrifft jetzt im
kern die persönliche ausstattung also
bekleidung schutzwesten nach zigarette
helme aber auch bewaffnung im einzelnen
und dann natürlich geht es um die
drängendsten großprojekte es muss ein
nachfolger für den veralteten tornado
gefunden werden auch ein neuer
transporthubschrauber die marine fragt
nach neuen fregatten und geboten doch
geld bloß nicht alles es gilt auch
vermögende entscheidungsprozesse zu
vereinfachen zum beispiel das
vergaberecht zu glauben wegen jedem
einzelnen kugelschreiber befasse ich das
parlament wer so an die sache herangeht
wird die 10 die 100 milliarden noch
nicht in 50 jahren abgeschlossen haben
vieles was die bundeswehr bislang
bestellte kam zu spät fehlerhaft oder
teurer von 350 puma schützenpanzern
beispielsweise sind derzeit 40
verwendungsfähig künftig will man
weniger selber entwickeln mehr von der
stange bestellen
wir müssen nicht und das war die letzten
jahre muss ich sagen schrecklich immer
alles selbst erfinden immer eine
deutsche lösung zu haben also der markt
bietet das an hin zur landes- und
bündnisverteidigung mit 100 milliarden
euro sondervermögen über jahrzehnte
gestreckt kann das ausgegeben werden
damit verspricht man sich
planungssicherheit in der vergangenheit
haben das ganz anders gemacht da haben
wir projekte in meiner kassenlage
gemacht was dazu geführt hat dass man
sie einfach eingestellt hat mittendrin
und damit im grunde genommen
steuergelder verbrannt hat vieles ist
bislang schief gelaufen bei der
beschaffung der bundeswehr offen ob die
100 milliarden ihre strukturellen
probleme zu lösen werden
altkanzler schröder sitzt seit jahren
den aufsichtsräten russischer gas und
ölfirmen und dieses engagement hat jetzt
offenbar folgen nach presseberichten
haben alle vier mitarbeiter seines
bundestagsbüros ihre posten niedergelegt
auch schröders langjähriger
redenschreiber und büroleiter obwohl es
viel druck auch aus der spd gibt
distanzierte sich schröder bislang nicht
klar von putin und hat auch seine arbeit
für russische unternehmen nicht beendet
der krieg in der ukraine hat auch in der
kultur konsequenzen valeri gergiev ist
als chefdirigent der münchner
philharmoniker entlassen worden gergiew
gilt als einer der berühmtesten
dirigenten unserer zeit die stadt
münchen hatte den 68 jährigen russen
ultimativ aufgefordert sich von putins
invasion der ukraine zu distanzieren
gergiew aber schwieg dazu dem meister
wird eine große nähe zu putin nachgesagt
zum krieg in der ukraine sehen wir auch
heute wieder ein zdf spezial gleich hier
im anschluss und zu jeder zeit auf dem
letzten stand der ereignisse und
entwicklungen sind sie mit unserem live
blog in der zdf- heute hätte
deutschlands verbraucher müssen wohl
weiter mit stark steigenden preisen
rechnen das ergibt sich aus der
aktuellen schätzung des statistischen
bundesamtes danach ist die
inflationsrate im februar auf 5,1
prozent gegenüber dem vorjahresmonat
gestiegen der ukraine konflikt ist hier
erst teilweise eingepreist angeheizt
wurde die teuerung zuletzt vor allem
durch die energiepreise sie sind im
februar im jahresvergleich um 22,5
prozent gestiegen für diese heizkörper
zahl theo baumstark mittlerweile 50
prozent mehr als vor einem jahr in
seiner wiesbadener sanitärfirma merken
sie die inflation besonders stahl kupfer
energie fast alles ist in den
vergangenen monaten deutlich teurer
geworden und das heißt auch die kunden
müssen mehr zahlen
kostensteigerungen sagt natürlich beim
material vergessen darf man auch die
spritkosten das heißt also sagen hier
ungefähr 40 wagen die fahren jeden tag
quer durch die stadt das heißt jeder tag
kostet mindestens moment 20 bis 30
prozent mehr und sprit ist muss man so
sehen theo baumstark spürt den
haupttreiber der hohen inflation energie
verglichen mit dem vorjahresmonat sind
die kosten dafür um 22,5 prozent
gestiegen mit dem krieg in der ukraine
drohen neue preissprünge das barrel öl
liegt erstmals seit vielen jahren wieder
deutlich über 100 dollar und auch gas
wird teurer die chemie industrie warnt
bereits vor einer preisexplosion
russland beteuert zwar dass sein gas
weiter fließen doch die unsicherheit
wächst ungefähr die hälfte unserer
gasimporte beziehen wir aus russland und
wenn putin jetzt in dieser
krisensituation entscheiden würde uns
den gashahn zuzudrehen dann drohte eine
energiekrise
dann könnte es auch zu einer rezession
kommen also von daher war es fahrlässig
sich so unabhängigkeit zu begeben von
russischen gasimporte viele hatten
gehofft dass sich die wirtschaft nach
dem corona schock erholt der krieg in
der ukraine zeigt aber deutschland und
europa sind nicht nur politisch
betroffen die wirtschaftlichen folgen
sind bisher kaum absehbar
für die mva werften in mecklenburg
vorpommern wurde heute das
insolvenzverfahren offiziell eröffnet
rund 1800 mitarbeiter sollen jetzt in
transfergesellschaften unterkommen so
sollen möglichst viele facharbeiter in
der region gehalten werden einige sollen
an dem fast fertigen kreuzfahrtschiff
global green weiterbauen für das es
mehrere kaufinteressenten gibt
dann blicken wir jetzt auf die korona
lage in deutschland die zahlen sinken
weiter das robert koch institut meldet
122.000 111 neue infektionen innerhalb
eines tages das sind knapp 3800 weniger
als vor einer woche
235 todesfälle kamen in 24 stunden dazu
und die sieben tage incidents geht
zurück auf jetzt
jetzt noch der blick nach australien die
hochwasserkatastrophe dort hat bislang
mindestens zehn menschen das leben
gekostet im osten des landes stehen
ganze landstriche unter wasser viele
bewohner des bundesstaates new south
wales müssen mit hubschraubern gerettet
werden rund 300.000 menschen sind
aufgerufen sich auf eine evakuierung
vorzubereiten es sind die schlimmsten
überschwemmungen seit jahrzehnten
ausgelöst durch tagelangen regen
fast nichts bleibt durch den krieg
unberührt katja die sportwelt greift
ziemlich hart durch es geht weiter der
russische sport muss sich immer mehr von
der internationalen bühne verabschieden
weil ein verband nach dem nächsten
athletinnen und athleten aus schließt
der sport zeigt sich vereint und setzt
zeichen gegen den krieg
sport ist für russlands präsidenten ein
symbol der macht und stärke das wird ihm
jetzt international entzogen
rekordweltmeister russland nicht
erwünscht bei der eishockey-wm des
internationalen verbandes eaa in
finnland am meisten bewegung gibt es in
den fußball verbänden fifa und uefa der
europäische dachverband trennt sich
nicht nur von bis zu 48 millionen euro
russischer sponsorengelder in der europa
liga ist spartak moskau ausgeschlossen
worden damit ist rb leipzig kampflos im
viertelfinale trainer tedesco hat spart
zwei jahre trainiert da sind enge
freundschaften entstanden die jetzt noch
bestand haben das habe ich schon
mehrmals gesagt natürlich tut es mir
leid aber das ist die einzig richtige
entscheidung markus gisdol ist heute als
trainer von lokomotive moskau
zurückgetreten und natürlich ist putins
angriff auf die ukraine der grund juli
wenn du trainer von sheriff tiraspol ist
seit dem sieg seines teams gegen real
madrid in der champions league ein
begriff ist 54 jahre alt jetzt zieht er
in den krieg die sanktionen gehen weiter
der internationale skiverband fis
schließt aktuell russische oder
belarussische athletinnen aus und morgen
wird entschieden ob die paralympischen
sportlern und sportlerinnen aus russland
oder belarus teilnehmen dürfen krieg hat
im sport nichts zu suchen hier muss ein
schlussstrich gezogen werden die
sportwelt wendet sich von russland ab
anderes thema kommendes jahr findet in
asien genau auf den philippinen in japan
und in indonesien die basketball wm
statt deutschland heißt die erste
qualifikations phase nahezu überstanden
gestern wieder ein sieg für das team von
gordon herbert der allerdings knapp aus
hier denn in heidelberg war israel lange
strecken das bessere team erst im
letzten viertel deutschland dann besser
und am ende mit 84 zu 80 punkten sieger
des abends nächstes spiel ende juni in
island dann hoffentlich zu friedlicheren
zeiten dankeschön katja auf eine
frostige nacht morgen wieder vielfach
sonnig mehr gleich von katja horneffer
marietta slomka meldet sich ab 21 uhr 45
mit dem heute journal
gleich nach wir uns wieder ein zdf
spezial zur ukraine lage das gesamte 19
uhr team bedankt sich fürs zuschauen und
wünschen noch einen guten abend
[Musik]
guten abend heute bekam die sonne etwas
konkurrenz durch wolkenfelder die der
von nordwesten heranzogen und dieses
wolkenband das reichte von südschweden
bis weit hinunter richtung galizien
schön zu erkennen auf diesen
satellitenbild auch dass sich in den
alpen noch immer schnee hält und sie
sehen auch die schneefreien taylor diese
dichteren wolken im nordwesten ziehen im
laufe der nacht etwas weiter nach
südosten aber zwischen der ostseeküste
dem alpenrand ist es doch auch häufig
klar und dann sinken die temperaturen
auf minus 4 bis minus 11 grad und am
kältesten wird es am alpenrand unter den
dichteren wolken nordwesten bleibt es
bei drei bis null grad milder kalt genug
für glätte ist es aber überall und
morgen wird es dann vor allen dingen an
den alpen einen richtigen
temperatursprung geben von dem minus elf
grad steigert sich das tagsüber auf plus
8 grad noch bilder wird es am
niederrhein mit 13 grad etwas kühler ist
es ganz im osten zum beispiel an der
ostseeküste mit 6 grad die dichteren
wolkenfelder der nacht ziehen morgen
dann ostwärts ab an der nordsee zeigt
sich gut die sonne aber von südwesten
kommen dichtere wolken heran die hängen
zusammen mit einem tief über frankreich
und mit ruhigem wetter im nordosten
etwas mit mehr wolken und doch recht
kalt geht es in den nächsten tagen
weiter im amt